hey guys I'm going to be promoting my
new podcast the way back here for the
next few weeks I'm very excited it's
going to drop every Thursday beginning
January 4th right here on my YouTube
channel you don't need to subscribe
anywhere else we'll work on getting it
out there wherever you get Podcast it
will be available but you can watch
video for sure right here on YouTube yes
I'm continuing the Honeydew it's just in
addition to that something fun something
a little different um going back to my
roots in podcasting a little bit so I'm
excited for it um it's called the way
back and it's just a Nostalgia podcast
sitting back on that that uh station
wagon back seat the one that looked out
in traffic you know that's the one the
best seat in the house talking about
growing up and you know just laughing
and having some good times you're going
to get the way back on patreon also a
day early you're going to get it ad free
as well um I'm really excited for this
show I really M it got a great response
when we dropped that first teaser and uh
our first guest to kick off is Tom
sagora so it's going to be a great one
we've got a bunch of them in the can
already um you're going to see Mark
Norman Jim Gaffigan Joe list they're all
on there all right uh so make sure
you're already subscribed and uh here's
a little taste for
you I remember growing up we were
terrible kid my brother was a bit of a
pyro take GI Joe's we would tape bottle
rockets we did the mailbox baseball
we're shooting BB guns Roman Candle
fights my mom didn't like anybody she
didn't even like her own kids these are
wire neighborhoods I didn't have a
curfew or a house how's all you bro a
dog chasing us was a drag queen M noan
Ryan that fast ball boom right my
brother's
face yeah those were the
[Music]
days
the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
[Applause]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler and Ryan sickler on all
your social media and I want to say
thank you like I do every week thank you
to everybody that watches subscribes
supports comments rates reviews all of
it I appreciate you whether you're new
here or whether you've been here thank
you and if you got to have more then you
got to have the patreon the patreon's
called the Honeydew with y'all and yall
have the wildest stories there's going
to be an end of the year episode we
already have pre-recorded with Josh Wolf
where we highlight again 10 of our
favorite episodes this will be the third
one there's trust me when I tell you the
30 episodes we've highlighted are worth
the patreon subscription all right those
alone you ain't going to find this on
Netflix all right and if you're looking
for a new podcast to listen to then you
got to check out the crab Feast it's my
old podcast I did with Jay Larson that
thing went it's hadn't been around for
five years in the library I say it every
week it did 1.1 million downloads last
year so thank you for keeping that alive
out there y'all and subscribe to my new
podcast the way back uh you'll see it
every Thursday right here on YouTube
it's going to be a little throwback
podcast some storytelling nostalgia that
good stuff all right for dates it's all
ryan.com all that stuff you know what
we're doing here we're highlighting the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers ladies
and gentlemen I am very excited to have
back on the Honeydew steo welcome back
to the Honeydew Steve yeah did my dog
princess fell in love with you right
away when you walked in IM immediately
she Lov she she liked me and then she
growled at me she did give you a growl
she did a little bit of a growl and then
I got over the hump yeah you did look at
her first time we've had her on the
Honeydew oh yeah wow yeah she comes in
she was scratching at the
door well before we get into whatever
we're going to talk about today please
plug promote you got the new special out
right now plug it all did they send you
a link they did we have a link they just
sent it did oh you didn't check it out
they sent it last night D bastard I got
it last night dude but I saw your clip
with Bert so I'm dying to watch it today
oh um dude it's it's really really
messed up man I've never heard anybody
say that about a stand up
special D it starts off tell us tell us
everything the first the first thing you
see when when the show starts is the
warning screen the warning screen uh
says warning the following contains
seriously effed up
S uh
including
um Reckless illegal
stunts um graphic
violence
nudity and fullon
pornography um it's that should just be
the log line it's it's uh and then then
the warning goes on
it's so effed up there's a chance you
may actually pass out
does it get that wild so you're
officially watching this at your own
risk all right I'm watching that at my
own risk tonight my daughter goes to bed
then lastly don't attempt anything
you're about to see yeah dude at the
taping taped it in two show two shows in
one night okay and at the first show
five people passed out in the audience
passed out yeah look I've worked with
you so I know what you did back when you
first started the Improv when you I well
right but but that was back in in the
beginning look I I know but you put
blood on you and you asked me to light
you on fire and I was like yeah I'm not
going to do that I'll hug you bro yeah I
I somebody light me on fire last night
um and the secret if I remember was it
Pantene leave-in
conditioner that's at least what you did
that night I'm pretty sure right well
that that was I would put I would put
conditioner in my hair so that when I
lit all my hair on fire it wouldn't like
you know the the just the accelerant
would burn and not the hair you know but
now I don't do it every night um every
night I remember you were squeezing
lemons in your eyes and doctors were
messaging you saying you will go blind I
know I think that's why I'm wearing
glasses yeah um yeah it's a tough gig
being steo a tough gig being steo and in
the beginning when I started doing
standup it was like you know what I'm
going to promise people I'm going to do
crazy stunts I'm going to like try to
lure him in with with the I'm doing
stunts on stage and uh you know let him
leave thinking man his standup was was
okay you know and and that's why I used
to do the the full meet and greet take
photos with the whole audience after and
uh I I kept doing that you know like but
it was just just me telling stories and
doing standup and then I'd just do a
couple tricks at the end of the show and
then when I put together my second hour
I was like oh my God like all the
stories I'm telling like really happened
on camera so I came up with the idea for
my second special to be like multimedia
where in post production I edit in
footage of the stories happening so you
see me telling the telling the story but
interstitially like it's
Illustrated it's Illustrated and that
that really worked so well man my second
special um it was called gnarly and it's
uh it's at sto.com streams completely
for free at this point that's the other
thing I love that you're doing is not
putting it on YouTube or anywhere you're
going R too.com yeah I know you
especially now now that it's like
multimedia and like that's that second
hour I I toured it you know the whole
time W without the benefit of the
multimedia component which which which
was important you know I didn't lean on
the footage like it was the show was
worthy in its own right of the of the
whole tour uh but man that multimedia
component added a lot in post production
so then when I came to do my third hour
I'm like man I gotta I gotta bring
footage on the road and I'm like
also I don't want to be living in the
past anymore because before it was like
an exercise and telling all my craziest
stories I was like I got to create new
crazy stories and bring the footage on
the road so I'm like how am I going to
do that how am I going to uh
raise the bar Jesus Christ dude the bar
is so H you've set the bar like what do
you mean raise it I I wanted to raise
the can I just pause you for one second
do you ever think now that you say this
do you ever think about a kid that's
going to come along inspired by you
who's maybe 15 right now that's going to
take your [__] where even you and your
70s are going to be like Jesus Christ
dude you ever think about that
um or are you being like nah y'all are
never gonna do it you're raising the how
old are you 49 you're raising the B I
love it I love [__] love me so what
does that mean tell me what that means I
I was thinking to myself I got to film
crazy crazier than ever new stuff and
like but what am I going to do like you
my buddies and I pretty much done
everything but I only thought that for
like a half a second I I was like yeah
no I know there's actually some ideas
I've been sitting around for for like
forever but they were never supposed to
happen
you know like uh the the main example of
one of these ideas was uh skydiving
where for like 20 years I I always said
like man if if I ever go skydiving I'm
gonna be butt ass
naked You' never been skydiving I had
never been skydiving I actually like old
dude I have a gnarly irrational fear of
roller coasters and bungee jumping n
that's irrational by the way but it's
counterintuitive you wouldn't think that
steo was afraid of roller coasters and
bunge of jumping but I totally am I
can't believe you got by not ever doing
that in jackass or anything all those
years I mean in in wild boys like like
way way like 20 years ago we were in
Costa Rica they took me to a 200 foot
bridge and they had built me these
Condor man wings so the gag was I'm
going to jump off the bridge and try and
fly but I was like guys you don't
understand like I will not be able to
bring myself to jump off that bridge
zero chance they're like yeah we'll talk
him into it you know and they couldn't
talk me to I was like I literally cannot
bring myself to do that I will not do it
and we settled on a compromise of having
five Costa Rican dudes do the mafia toss
where they pick me up and throw me off
oh so you still went but you made to
make it I went but I just like that way
I have to do anything you know I
wouldn't have been able to jump [__]
thre up did it work did the WIS the
wings the wings did not
work but because I I had I mean and I
can point any body to that footage as
like proof I'm not kidding that I don't
like that stuff I can't I don't like it
so whenever skydiving came up I had this
idea as a way of avoiding having to do I
was like oh man skydiving is not a stun
everybody does that come on dude it's
like if I go skyd I'm gonna be butt
naked and furiously jacking off with
another man strapped to my back plus I'm
G to time it so that I'm actually
blowing a load as I fall out of the
airplane
that's our first promo right there for
real does the dude on your back know
that you're going to be doing okay all
right
yeah we ended up like not being able to
get a get a company like or or anybody
you know to sign off on it so I went on
my social media asking for licensed
tandem skydive
professionals we ended up having 20
dudes say let's
go 20 of them so I went with the only
guy who said
[Laughter]
[Music]
please yeah oh were you able to get your
dick hard with that level of fear and
everything I had four seis pills for
breast okay all right all right four of
them Jesus Christ that was my breakfast
dud and and I brought a portable you
could have landed on that [__]
yeah you brought a what you looking a
porn portable DVD player and I and I I
was backed up for four days so you made
it happen well you got to watch the
special watch the special I mean did
like that that's like uh you can't do
that for Jackass no you can't and uh and
you can't flagrantly break the law
either man like I had medical
professionals straight stealing drugs
from the hospital what do you mean
stealing General anesthesia drugs which
they administered through an IV in my
vein while I'm hauling ass on a bicycle
through a
field and you know what I can't wait
to you know what an epidural is yeah
just had three of them yeah you have 4in
needle in your spine yeah yeah I I got
that [__] inject the drug into my spinal
cavity yank out the needle and I take
off to see how far I could run no are
you [__] kidding me yeah for sure and
then once I'm down then there then the
the experiments begin to see how if I'm
really
paralyzed paralyzed well yeah the thing
paralyzed were you partially like did
they do some [__] where you couldn't
feel it at all they did Dark [__] dark
[__] and you're you're watching your own
legs like that well the thing was though
like uh like the one thing they told me
to watch out for is if I become
paralyzed to above the wayist cuz then
[__] starts shutting down and and I I
[__] couldn't feel anything my whole
chest is numb I'm [__] can't breathe
it's the scariest [__] thing I've
ever been through right at that moment
right there what starts going through
your head do you really do you start do
you have thoughts like okay this
bullshit's not worth it you go there at
all well I'm like I'm in a field you
know like the the the Medical
Professional is actually dressed up as a
clown but he is a real profession
I I won't reveal where it
was he's actually wearing it like clown
can you imagine driving by looking in a
field seeing some clown work on Ste like
that steo dud I'm [__] freaking out
I'm like dude for me to like it was so
difficult for me to breathe I could
barely muster enough breath to say I'm
having trouble breathing dude I've
watched you do hours and hours and hours
of the most [__] up [__] and you're
telling me this was up there level scary
yeah because I'm like here I'm my [__]
my systems are shutting down are you can
you you could raise your arms or I could
raise my arms but I couldn't feel my
chest or any indication that I was able
to breathe Jesus Christ and uh for how
long about 45 minutes oh my god dude I
would have thought I was paralyzed
forever for almost an hour if for yeah I
wasn't worried about paralyzed forever I
was worried about like you know unable
to breathe in dead because that you know
like um so yeah that one was unable to
breathe in
dead that's a good one to
work yeah and like after the bit I'm
still laying there on the ground I just
start sobbing dude crying like and this
weird doctor guy first time he shows any
emotion throughout this whole ordeal
he's confused as to why I'm sobbing and
and he asks what what's happening
through my tears I say the bar for my
stuns is so [__]
high we just raised it dude just tears
of joy because I just I just raised the
bar it's so hard to do that and uh yeah
man it's a it's a big deal and so like
the way that it works yeah I filmed all
this stuff I put together a whole hour
for it you know like the show is a
journey through the bucket list and each
bit gets paid off with the actual
footage of the Forbidden stunt taking
place and the stunts are
presented in descending order of the
approval and support of my
fiance in the beginning she's all about
it but these are all new stunts yeah
this is stuff you've never seen before
done before hell yeah so in the
beginning she's all about it in the
beginning like my where's it shift
where's it shift in the beginning like
my my buddies are running for their
lives and barfing and she's standing
strong dude like moving in for a better
shot and that's like the one where I'm
like that's how I knew she's the one so
you know
so I knew I had to put a ring on it and
then it's like all right so we got
engaged like that which begs the
question are we gonna have kids are you
n dude that's the next stunt the
vasectomy
Olympics and she's all about it you know
she's like no like telling when I'm
dressed up as a pinata like like
immediately after my vasectomy with kids
whacking me in the balls with a stick
she's like no hit him in the
balls yeah like uh it's heavy dude how
long is it how long's the special an
hour and five minutes you got an hour
and five minutes of new stunts the of
this level of [__] it's uh I mean it's
it's it's standup meets jackass you know
like yeah I'm just saying it's a lot of
content a lot of stunts there's like 10
there's 10 items on the list and it's
got a heavy credit
bed yeah that the credit bed's so much
fun and dude the beginning the opening
sequence I've [__] shot it with Bill
Burr did you hell yeah and it cost over
$150,000 for about a minute and a half
of footage just the opening sequence
yeah couldn't be more [__] St stoked
on it like it was a big gamble I was
like dude I I want to be on a [__]
roof and I want a [__] big ass
helicopter and I want the [__]
helicopter to drop a rope ladder I grab
it with my bare hands and it flies off
and I'm dangling around I want to get
[__] crashed through all kinds of
[__] and then I want the helicopter
flying over my moving tour bus and I got
to let go and land on the roof of the
moving tour bus and uh you know and then
um and then more [__] happens after that
too um Jesus Christ yeah B I just used
audio audience Applause to walk on the
stage Jesus Christ you do all that yeah
come on dude I swear to God you'll see
it in the opening sequence and Bill
Bird's a helicopter
pilot that's [__] awesome dude
yeah yeah I mean oh great candidly we
shot the the all the stunts and then
after the fact I showed it to Bill bur
and I was like hey can we go up in a
helicopter with you and film you for
insert shots to cut to you flying the
hell to make you the pilot like he
wasn't there for the stunt day but the
fact of of him being such a bro like
yeah dude [__] yeah I'll do that for you
you rent the helicopter I'll fly it and
uh it's a big deal for me being you know
steo from Jackass coming in to stand up
everyone's looking sideways at me like
and and have Bill bur sign off Bill the
dude yeah yeah like my my first standup
special the the opening was me in the
dressing room like effectively
apologizing for the fact that you were
about to watch me do stand up comedy
then this my second special started with
a billboard
truck with uh like the like the art for
my special on the billboard and all the
jackass guys reunited to duct tap me to
the billboard I remember that one yeah
hit baseballs at me and then drive me to
the theater down the highway you know
before you perform right that and that
that was that was epic because it was
like my jackass you know the my first
special nobody signed up I me you know
my second special all the jackass guys
got together to symbolically you know
give me their blessing and send me down
the road and then the third one I got
Bill bur signing off on me I mean come
on it's epic it is epic yeah good for
you steo I love the way you're doing it
well thanks man I really do like the way
you're doing it it's scary yeah it's
scary as [__] it's scary but I mean
literally way more for you you're
[__] yeah it's scary but dude like
I'm I'm so [__] stoked on this sorry
for S I know it's not good to load up
on um but yeah dude I'm uh I'm really
really hyped on on this one man it's the
best thing I've ever made and and if you
like put my first special and this like
next to each other like man I'm so
stoked on uh having that turd of first
special as a milestone for how far I've
come since then good for you yeah so
everybody at sto.com check out my bucket
list special and dude let's get into it
dude what do we got um well I want to
talk to you because you know look we do
this weekly we've talked about who
whatever everything so where's little
lady oh she's behind you um get some
water I want to ask
you let's talk about I want I told you I
wanted to do like a parallel thing where
I ask you about the most most
embarrassing stunt you've done for
Jackass or entertainment embarrassing in
one in what way you tell me like
anything that humiliated you or where
you where you look back you're like man
regret versus something an actual moment
that happened in real life I want to see
if real life is stranger than what you
guys can create do you understand what
I'm saying sure so you can go either way
with that oh look who it
is um to think of uh embarrassing or
regrettable moments in
jackass
clearly
um it's
not this is saying it's better to regret
the things that you have done than to
regret the things that you haven't done
and uh I really really you know hold
that dear to my heart because um give me
one of each regret the things that I I
did do when it comes to jackass when it
comes to like things going bad or
getting hurt like you know the worst the
consequences the better the footage you
know like I really don't have too much
regret well okay I regret the baby
tattoo that wasn't even for
Jackass but uh
you know I got this I I got this crazy
tattoo and it it haunts me till this day
man like there's a it's never going to
why you get it um I mean dude I I had uh
I was just into getting dumb tattoos man
I would get like the most regrettable
tattoo on purpose because that like that
was a stunt you know I had uh like the
like fullon profanity tattooed on my
Knuckles you know like the the my right
hand was the SW word my left hand was
the f
word like uh four-letter words on my
Knuckles tattooed you know I was just
like all right what next you know like I
had a big like wiener tattooed like you
know like it was like like how do I get
more and more aggressive with the most
regrettable possible t let see this
tattoo on your head right now right
here yeah I mean that that that's kind
of kind of mellow but uh that's new wish
though isn't that a new is that your
latest tattoo on your body yeah I think
so yeah yeah I'm part of my new hour I'm
working on is a a crash test dummy
bit bro it's there it looks good yeah
that's it
like I got a lot of crashing to do man
um so the baby tattoo the baby are you
working on getting that removed I got it
covered up yeah oh you got it covered up
yeah yeah um yeah that was the that that
was the the most regret um but other
than that I don't really uh regret
anything too too much I regret things
that that you know harmed other people
you know you never want to like do harm
to others but anything that harmed me is
all pretty good what about um being
embarrassed embarrassed that's or or
wait before we go to embarrass regret is
there anyone that you regret that you
didn't do oh yeah yeah what was one you
always wanted to do that you didn't get
to do that's all of my regrets man we
were in India and they had uh
[Music]
this this bed of hot coals that took all
day to get set up to make it right MH
and they had a a balance
beam like a it was like a plank in the
air like kind of like a gymnastics
balance beam over the hot coals and my
job was to ride a unicycle on the you
say un cycle yeah like and so obvious
hot yeah like obviously I'm gonna fall
and go into the hot the hot coals but
there's just something about being on
that balance beam that I just couldn't
commit with both feet to getting on the
unicycle and I just wimped out I didn't
do it and and that haunted me forever
man it did yeah have you ever gone back
and done it that was on the second movie
when we were in India and then on the
third movie we uh we did dead a fire
swinging fire Gauntlet look the farmer's
dog is back thanks to you guys and
princess and I couldn't be happier
everybody here works man everybody here
works the farmer's dog was founded by
two dog lovers who decided to reimagine
pet food from the ground up the farmer's
dog makes and delivers fresh healthy dog
food it's developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and made from
real healthy ingredients to human food
safety standards not only that it's also
pre-portioned specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
this makes it easy to help your dog
maintain their ideal weight which is one
of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life a fresh diet has been found
to have all sorts of benefits from
healthier coat and skin to better breath
even easier digestion and smaller better
poops all things I've noticed with
Princess Lily Rose right here doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you live more
healthy happy and full years together
get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com
honeydo plus you get free shipping just
go to farmers.com honeydo to get 50% off
that's Farmers
do.com honeydo bedday are self-care for
the selfless because even busy parents
poop and can take five for their butt
Health look I've been using tushi for a
long time I love it I never had one
prior to tushi and I don't like pooping
anywhere else I don't like going
anywhere else I will save it to get home
and risk messing my pants to use my
tushy with over 100,000 fstar reviews
see why millions of real pooping humans
already love hello tushi bedet every
hello tushi bedet attachment comes with
a 30-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty hello tushy bedday
fresh stream of water cleans your bum
two times better than wiping even if you
use wet wipes you're still smearing poop
around and introducing nasty chemicals
to your butt using a hellow tushy b day
also prevents poo particles from
spreading your hands and Everything You
Touch like my hands at the meet and
greets it attaches to your existing
toilet requires no electricity or
additional plumbing and cuts toilet
paper used by
80% a hello tushi bedet pays for itself
in under a year take care of yourself
from the bottom up this holiday season
visit hellotushy.com
honeydew and use promo code honeydew for
$10 10% off your first order that's
hellotushy.com
honeydo for 10% off hellotushy.com
honeydo this bustling holiday season you
might be looking for nutritious
flavorful meals to fuel you on jam-pack
days Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal delivery service can help
you eat well for breakfast lunch and
dinner with Chef prepared dietition
approved ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door you'll save time
and stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle while tackling all your
holiday to-dos if you're looking for
calorie conscious options that don't
skip on Flavor then you can try
delicious dietitian approved calor smart
meals with around or less than 550
calories per serving or if you need an
extra boost to support your Wellness
goals and fill your best during the
holidays try Protein Plus meals with 30
grams of protein or more per serving
with Factor you can rest assured you're
making a sustainable choice they offset
100% of their delivery emissions and
Source 100% renewable electricity for
their production sites and offices this
December get factor and enjoy eating
well without the hassle simply choose
your meals and enjoy fresh flavor pack
meals delivered to your door ready in
just two minutes no prep No Mess listen
I'm going to say this I have them I have
a stack of them they sent me they're
delicious they're all under 550 calories
they even have some shakes I have a
strawberry banana shake to start the
morning um it's delicious it's not like
that old you know microwave throwing the
freezer foods it's not like that that at
all it's really good for you so head to
factor meals.com honeydo 50 and use code
honey dw50 to get 50% off that's code
honeydew 50@ factor meals.com
honeydo to get 50% off now let's get
back to the D what else do I
regret
I wonder why yeah I'm kind of drawing a
blank so I guess uh I didn't wimp out
that many
[Laughter]
times um how about uh you said most
embarrassing you were going there next
yeah most
embarrassing I mean
uh I'm embarrassed of the fact that back
in the wild
boy I'm embarrassed for the fact that
back in the wild boys days
I um shot at a like SeaWorld type Place
riding dolphins in captivity you know
like the big Orca with his fin flopped
over you got own one of those I didn't
get on the Orca but I was riding
Dolphins around and we shot with the
Orca with its fin flopped over you know
um to go on to be like Mr like SeaWorld
is a bad place and have that in my past
is pretty rough talk about that like
what made you what made did you realize
was it that that made you realize like
this shit's crazy I I just became more
sensitive about animal stuff over the
years of course I was impacted by the
Blackfish
documentary
um I don't know at the time like back
then in Argentina and filming Wild Boys
in like 2004 or five or whatever it was
didn't even register that that it was
bad and so you know I I I I'll plead
ignorance but yeah that that
sucked yeah but at least you're growing
as a person and a man you're not you
know but also you guys did crazy [__] I
remember did I not see you guys like
next to gorillas and [__] NE like as
close as we are not quite as close as
are pretty damn close a gorilla could
get to you in a second oh yeah and and
that those were legitimately wild
mountain gorillas in Rwanda that's
fing
yeah that was Heavy dude dude I remember
seeing that thing like at any moment it
could just rip your [__] head off
yeah they we're like dude these these
GRS could kill us yes we better put on
the banana suits yeah that's what you
did then you put on banana suits and ran
around it wasn't enough
just yeah that was pretty awesome the
the wild animal stuff definitely was
dangerous tigers you ever [__] W big
cats big cats yes but they were all uh
like somewhat controlled environments
with
um captive you know
uh captive big cats that were in
California so like when we were in the
zebra suit and got mauled by the lion
that's what I'm saying it's not enough
that happened in California like when we
were in the hammock with the meat you
know hanging from it and the
lions that was in California there there
was one where we had a tiger pounce on
us while we were in an inflatable dingy
and popped the dingy and that happened
in California dude what is what is the
power and pressure of one of those big
cats coming down on you feel like well
like when I'm up in the tree for the
Nintendo commercial that was in
California too that was uh that I was
resigned to it being that's it you know
like like I'm dead yeah they climb and
I'm I like I remember thinking like man
I was pretty pretty badass about that I
didn't [__] out I just kind of went
limp and here here goes wait what like
uh I had a really close call with the
lion in a tree and it was on my back
like kind of like not in a suit or
anything like just legit on your back
what what is that feel
like like it felt like my last
moments did you really think is is it
yeah for sure I mean all it has to do is
prick your neck just accidentally just
one of those I said I said good kitty
good kitty 200 lb line and I'm like good
kitty good kitty and I just kind of went
limp and and uh just it was no longer
interested well yeah they uh they they
brought in some uh some some meat to
like hey K have this me over
here so it got off me dude what what
about scariest like one where
you in life give me a give me one in
real life [__] jackass for a second in a
respectful way tell me real life [__] if
if my fiance heard this like I'm a bad
driver are you really yeah and I haven't
ConEd celebra in that spot out there
today though pretty nice okay um I just
like I I have a lot of thoughts happen
at once you know while you're driving
just all the time man like my my head is
really loud and and like you know there
just a lot happening in my head and um
and and it comes out as bad driving you
know yeah um and we just bought this
prop I can't believe I'm going to admit
this man we bought this property in
Tennessee and um like when we took
pizette when I'm just gonna say say this
more cleanly
my lady and I bought this property in
Tennessee and it just worked out that
the day the previous owners moved out
was the first day after my tour okay and
I had to connect flights to get home so
I was like all right I'll connect in
Tennessee spent a couple days there so I
was by
myself and I rented a car I'm driving
around and like there was this point
where I'm just driving and I realized
that not only did I blow a stop sign but
I drove into the highway what a 65 mph
speed limit highway just straight
through and on I mean it's just like a
highway that doesn't have how fast are
you going I mean I'm just going like
kind of normal like like 30 40 like I
don't know but like it is just by chance
that that uh that there wasn't a car
that just straight T-Bone so gnarly and
that chance wasn't so good like going
into the the next Lane of the other
direction like I'm
like oh my god dude like that that the
the worst bad driving thing and and
uh I almost died like I mean not almost
died I just I could have died straight
up yeah yeah like and and I mean the
speed limit on that is 65 who knows what
they're actually
doing and why it's a highway that you
can get on without an on-ramp is beyond
me all right so here's another question
I have for you what do you do to calm
down you say your mind's always going
you're always going you're always
wanting to raise the bar you're always
boom boom boom what do you ever do you
know how to relax I know I don't I know
I don't do you know how to do that do
you know how to do you take naps what
the [__] do you do are your adrenaline
put you down meditating every day twice
a
day uh yeah
I I keep track of it on an app and uh
check it out dude um my uh I've done
since December 27th 2019 I've meditated
1419 days hell yeah stra averaging 41
minutes a day totaling 900 76 hours you
know I broke my streak when I went to
Australia like uh the time
zone oh like that doesn't count no you
can't blame yourself for that my longest
streak was 1199 days wow dude but still
I'm averaging 41 minutes every what made
you start doing that
um it's Brussel
Brandon I mean I I subscribed to the
idea that that meditation was helpful
yeah I would say and uh Russell Brand in
2013 he was like oh dude you know like
you got to meditate and and he hooked me
up with this meditation teacher and I
kind of dabbled in it you
know and then
dude the meditation teacher was from
this David Lynch Foundation right and
I'm like okay dude you know I'm going to
the teacher I'm meditating and my
meditation teacher said say Hey you know
like we're we're trying to stop the
prison the school to prison pipeline in
like Los Angeles you know like all these
kids are going to so trying to bring
meditation into the inner city schools
and and help you know help these kids
like we get behind I'm like hell yeah
this was in 2015 when I was taping my f
getting ready to tape my first special I
was like hell yeah so like I do this big
fundraiser thing I'm like I'm giving
away VIP tickets to somebody no matter
where you are in the world to come be at
the taping of my special and there's all
these different tiers of like prizes
that that you can win certain donations
get you certain things everything gets
you a chance at a bigger thing and I
promoted it like crazy on all platforms
promote promote
promote and uh God damn that like I'm
I'm looking at it I'm like I'm doing all
this stuff the David Lynch Foundation
never acknowledged anything that I was
doing like they didn't like there I was
like wow that's weird I'm doing all this
stuff tagging them and stuff they're not
sharing it they're not following me back
they're not sharing it they're like like
I'm but they asked you that my teacher
did I don't know if like with the
organization but the thing was when you
go into the David Lynch like little
headquarters it's just like a celebrity
circle jerk in there you got the the
walls are plaster plastered Paul m
cartney Russell Brand uh Jerry Seinfeld
like they just can't have enough
celebrities on the wall and like I want
her to be in in in the club you know
like they didn't have to put me on the
wall but like don't act and I was just I
just got so like uh just offended man
you know I I I was offended that that
they were just like not even
acknowledging all of this effort that I
was doing to for them and so I quit
I gave up my spiritual practice out of
resentment okay and then like years went
by you
know I wasn't really meditating and and
then I was like dude I'm blowing it like
here my resentment towards this David
Lynch they they teach Transcendental
Meditation I was going to ask if it was
TM it was TM and I was just like man
screw those people you know maybe
meanwhile maybe they didn't I don't know
how they couldn't know when I'm tagging
them and everything I posted but I was
just like screw them and and as the
years went by I
thought I'm kind of blowing it dude I
think I would benefit from meditating
but it was just had that Grudge and then
uh like uh you know I caught when I saw
this thing this guy offering to teach
vdic meditation a slightly different
thing and I was like you know what I'm
going to start over I'm gon to start
over with a new thing new deal and and I
went to this this new teacher in in
December of 2019 and and I learned
hilariously that what's called vadic
meditation is literally the same thing
as Transcendental Meditation you have
you get a mantra even I've been through
I've been taught in both things the the
the process was identical down to the
little ceremony with the flowers with
the the whole thing there's literally no
difference there's no reason to to
distinguish there's nothing that a
marketing thing then is that what the
but but the best thing about it is that
there's there's like a low grade war
between the viic meditation people and
the T they do the same thing meditation
people were fighting each other bro
they're like oh well those people and
then these people you know and like
who's who swears their
first I'm not even sure I would have to
guess the viic people are first but the
thing is it's like dude oh there's beef
oh
man yeah oh yeah there's beef I like
these spiritual people are beef
spiritual beef and I'm like dude I'm in
tm's a
joke I do vadic okay and I do it every
day I do it every day I do it every day
no matter what and I genuinely like I
have this genuine belief that because I
have a discipline meditation practice
practice I believe that the Universe
conspires in my favor I believe that I'm
protected I believe that I have a
relationship with the
universe and you know I got I got to
tell the truth all the time I got to do
the right thing all the time and I got
to put in my meditation if I do that
everything's
cool everything GNA be good that's my
faith how long have you been clean and
sober now 15 years that's a long time is
that crazy that is crazy 15 years and
sexual
sober meaning like no acting out in
faithful
faithful but you mean single as well not
going crazy you got you got to remember
back like in you know when I was doing
the comedy like I was like oh dude I'm
in you know like I'm not I'm not beating
off like I'm not like I'm I'm you know
working on I went to sex addict rehab in
2013 you did I did what was why what
made you think or what made you I don't
know what who told you whatever you had
an addiction it was um I mean like I I
used you know like I said I used to do
the the meet and greets after every show
and that was like a glorified audition
to figure out like who I was going to
hook up with out of the audience you
know like I was gnarly on the road just
trying to hook up with chicks all the
time and as I approached 40 you know I
approached 40 years old and I was like
this isn't it man you know like this is
isn't how I'm like this isn't a path to
being like happy in life like especially
later in life like I I really believed
if I'm G to be happy in life I got to
learn how to be in a healthy
relationship I got to knock it off with
the running around trying to hook up
with chicks I tried to quit and I
couldn't I just couldn't and and like I
got into therapy I did the whole thing
and and um my Mantra was I'm going to do
the work to become the man that the love
of my life deserves and that's that was
my deal man you know and uh I had to do
a lot of work to be ready to meet what's
my girl now we've been together for
almost seven years and like uh I
haven't done I haven't done a damn thing
good you know like to behave all the
time in a way that if my girl had like a
like a
drone like follow all the time yeah for
sure you want my location I don't give a
[__] whatever take it we got our thumb
prints our our face recognition and and
she's welcoming my phone 100% of the
time we share locations like see I've
been the opposite of you and but for you
know like and I have past relationships
too where they don't believe me like
there's no way you don't [__] on the
road I'm like I'm telling you I've
always been scared of a few things one
is just having a ro baby big time like I
would want to be I want to be I always
wanted to be a dad and I didn't want to
have a kid with I'm living in LA and
somebody's in [__] whatever Omaha or
something you know what I mean the other
thing is and this is what I had Gareth
Reynolds we talked about was um I've
always been skeptical I always feel
like you're going to take me to your
place or you're going to come back to my
place going to drug me Rob me whatever
or your boyfriend or husband's going to
be there [__] me up Rob me so I've just
never never one time ever but I can't
get nobody believes it I'm like I get
why you don't believe it but I'm telling
you on the road nah wow that's
impressive but I'm just cuz I'm scared
I'm [__] scared I'm like nah I don't
there isn't a chick out there that's
worth getting [__] up in some Marriott
you know what I mean I was never worried
about getting uh you never thought of
that you're high-profile you never
thought of being jumped and robbed or
anything set up like that know but I was
just always worried about like oh my God
like what did I put my wiener into this
time
I got to go I got to go get checked out
like you know there's a lot of uh just
stress man stress and chaos and just
time wasted time wasted the amount of
time that gets burned up trying to chase
chicks around is stupid and now like I
you know I'm just now you got the one
yeah yeah and like there's a lot of
there was a lot of Shame involved too
you know just like man like this using
people like exploiting PE you know like
this just not there was a lot of Shame a
lot of stress a lot of you know guilt
and and
uh so that was you've been sex clean
again how long sexually sober coming up
on seven years okay so this relationship
then yeah yeah good for you and then but
but clean 15 15 years no drugs no booze
what's the what's the last you used and
why why did you finally say enough did
you have an intervention it did get a
little blurry when I'm on when I'm
riding a bicycle around like getting
shot up with general
anesthesia but I did that in
consultation and that was actually a a a
revision to the stunt and the stunt
started out the idea was to get shot
like one of my buddies and I line up for
a foot race and it starts like on your
Market set they shoot tranquilizer darts
into our butt cheeks and we see who can
run you know the farthest but the
tranquilizer
darts have [__] animal tranquilizer
in it and like everybody knows that's
ketamine oh [__] I didn't think of that
and I [__] love ketamine I can't
[__] [__] with that you know so I was
like oh and I got close to doing it dude
we found we found the guy with the
tranquilizer Dark Gun he's like dude I
got a veterinarian doesn't give a [__]
you know like the veterinarians ready to
load up the darts with ketamine like it
was on and that [__] dose what would
that do to you I mean dude like that's
like who knows like jumping inside a
heroin needle that kind of dose going
that [__] takes down an elephant like
who knows man but it was ready to go we
had like all we had to do was jump on
the plane and go do it and and like I
wanted to do that bad like I'm an
ambitious cat and I had like this is the
biggest Conflict for me like my two most
important things like get the footage
you know like raise the bar like my
ambition like was just at odds with my
recovery like I got to stay sober to
stay alive and I gotta you know like and
I was losing my mind dude like losing my
mind like I was basically picking
footage over SB yeah I was ready to go I
was like dude it's only one time you
know even that one time I feel like any
even I've never done it I feel like if I
got shot in the ass with with that Dart
I'd be addicted would be addicted who
knows but but ultimately like uh Common
Sense prevailed and I arrived at the
conclusion like okay I'm not doing that
but I gotta like I got to go down this
path that's what I love about you it's
not like no we're not going to do that
not change this yeah we're going to do
it I just got to figure out I was just
like the tranquilizer dart foot race is
not it but but in sobriety I've had hell
of surgeries what do you mean oh I've
had all kinds of surgeries endoscopies
you name it like I've been knocked out
for general anesthesia a bunch of times
and it never relapsed okay good cuz
that's Fentanyl and [__] like that too I
got fentanyl in a valume the last time I
got three epidurals and they were like
are you okay and I was like yeah and I
did you did you have that uh in your own
possession after you left the hospital
no no just what they gave me to put me
out there and I I thought about that and
I was like wow you're really giving me a
responsible obvious VI L legal dose of
this [__] but the last thing I remember
is they were tucking a pillow under my
stomach she goes you okay I'm like I'm
good boom I wake up I'm in another room
in a chair sounds like that sounds like
like propol not he told me Fentanyl and
Valium I'm just telling you what he told
me I mean I woke up and I was like how
did I get here and they're like you
walked here and I was like wow I mean
I'm not doubting it you know whatever
I've never even filled out a
prescription for a painkiller like like
when I left the hospital I'll take
whatever the doctors want to give me to
do the procedure you know whatever it's
not it's not in my possession I'm not
taking it if the doctor thinks I need it
I'll tell him look I'm a drug addict you
know but when you leave what do you do
for pain then just over the counter
Advil Tylenol okay in the most
horrifying situations both of them at
once you do really does it work yeah
does it dud the most effective pain
management there is he selling that on
this show I love it 100% on Avil
together yeah for sure like when I when
I shattered my ankle and had 11 screws
to screw it together no pain meds no
pain meds dude T that was Tylenol plus
adal like uh and that helped I know
that's not going to take the pain away
but it help it was it was still it was
still horrific but yeah that help that
helped a lot that got me through it and
so yeah I was like dude like general
anesthesia I've done it a ton of times
never relapsed so doing the general
general anesthesia bike ride is cool and
and I with my like my sober Community
like you know everybody knew like even
in my crew I sober people it's like all
right you know very clear on why I'm
doing this it's for work it's it's on
camera and uh I'm getting shot up with
how far did you get well that one
like when you're in surgery they
intubate you you know like you like
because you completely stopped breathing
and
so like being in a field riding a
bicycle and stopping breathing is kind
of scary we we did hire an ambulance we
were ready if we had to and it's so
funny like we did this at Dave England's
house but he didn't know I was like hey
can I shoot at your house he's like yeah
he's got five
acres like yeah for sure but he didn't
know what we were shooting so we get
there and there's an ambulance he's like
what's that for like like oh yeah we're
doing a general anesthesia bike ride and
his like whole face goes like white cuz
he thinks like that he's going to have
to do it for some reason I'm like oh no
no it's just me riding like he goes oh
okay cool you know yeah like once he
once he knew that he was off the hook
and there was no pressure for him to do
it like somehow like he was so relieved
it didn't even occur to him that it
might be problematic that I could die on
his property but uh they were very
everyone was pretty sensitive about the
stopping breathing thing so the game
plan was to give it to me bit by bit to
just get me to the point where I was out
but not like needing to be intubated and
that was
uh with like like if you look on Google
the drug is called
etomidate I went with that one because
it's not a substance of abuse like
propol
etomidate you give a man a full grown
man 8 milligrams of atom he's out for
surgery for real yeah and we we we
stole a vial of 20
milligrams you only need eight yeah
eight eight eight at once that's enough
to put a man out for surgery where they
don't feel the pain and everything
everybody's going to be different you
know everybody different but yeah
average like that's that's what Google
[Laughter]
[Music]
said what Google so we got so we got
about two and a quarter [__] servings
of this thing huh yeah so we we had uh
20 milligram they gave me two at once
and I'm like not even close give me two
more you know I need more like and at
this point I'm like oh give me more you
know just crazy and uh [__] man they
gave me all 20 milligrams I'm still
riding around n dude yeah you took all
20 you're still pedaling that [__]
but yeah that's CU like they get by
giving it to me bit by bit like uh I
don't know it's like cycling you know
you kind it's got to be all at once to
get to get me down and and and I don't
know that anybody really knew that
everybody thought it was going to work
work but then so that bit with the bike
ride isn't even about crashing the bike
because I'm unconscious it's about like
what a [__]
raving
[__] lunatic on drugs I became
immediately like drug drugs enter my
body and I'm [__] you know like in
the in the footage you see me get
loaded like on drugs loaded acting
loaded
[__] drugged up tempered tantrum
freak out and are you do you remember
that or you do okay yeah I remember it
and I remember it being the most [__]
traumatizing thing because the bit was a
failure because I didn't I wasn't
knocked out like I I was [__]
humiliated by uh the way I behaved and
like now my sobriety was in question
like dude am I even a sober guy just got
[__] loaded you know
so uh for a for a while I was pretty
shaky on that one like it it it [__]
me up and the bit was a
failure but then I [__] meet this guy
and he's like I got you
dog he says I got a away you can finish
your bit and you don't have to worry
about your sobriety because it's not
even going to affect like how it's just
going in your spine we're going to
paralyze just your bottom half and that
was the I was like dude my recover I
don't have to worry about sobriety like
let's [__]
go and that was the one where Lux was
like okay I'm now I'm not showing up
that's where she stopped showing up yeah
and now when you did that you were you
didn't feel that same like more more
more from that I did not now man like uh
it was just my my you know from the neck
down
M yeah that one was yeah so it's all
pretty [__] intense stuff man yeah
please look first of all thank you for
coming on here and doing this show and
telling these stories but plug and
promote the name where ste's bucket list
it's ato.com I brought Jeff Tain the
director of Jackass over like like uh
long time ago couple years ago to show
them like a a video of a performance
with all the multimedia baked in I was
like dude you and me taine we go to
Netflix and it's from the director of
Jackass like what what Jackass couldn't
show like this crazy like thing I was
like I think we can [__] make this
happen he watched it he
goes
buddy you know like he's like dude
you've outdone yourself and I'm real
proud of you but this isn't going
anywhere near Netflix pal like this is
like from start to finish like like I
don't see any even a part of this that
could be on
Netflix so it's like all right you're
right you know I'm not centuring and I'm
not toning it down and and I'm putting
out myself and so good for you dude for
for people to support that and and uh
and support me and that's a big deal
dude if you go to sto.com and that'll
mean the world to me and I promise I
promise this will not disappoint anybody
somebody might pass out yeah if you're
the kind of person who passes out then
set up a camera when I warn
you dud thank you very much for doing
this than you brother hell yeah yeah as
always Ryan sichler on all social media
ransler docomo talk to youall next
[Music]
[Applause]
week